I have had enough I've had enough of
being told what to think enough for
people being bullied and threatened and
shut down I've had enough of tiptoeing
around the permanently offended Brigade
and almost every day is seeing yet
another example of people being forced
to retract something and issue an
apology because the social justice
warriors have demanded that they do so
whether it's a school closing down its
decade-long farming project because the
vegandon
eye care tube workers removing factually
historical references because some
people felt offended or brands
apologising for advertising in certain
publications just because some people
don't like it people are now terrified
of causing a fence and have been made
social pariahs the permanently offended
Brigade and not only trying to erase
history they are trying to erase any
difference of opinion at all we are on a
slippery slope and trust me we need to
hit the brakes as a matter of urgency
right so the pig farming school let's
let's see there was a petition set up by
a vegan so you're outraged ah yeah so
there's a vegan parent who was outraged
Michele's outraged at him that that the
school was wearing pigs and was then
going to send the pigs to slaughter and
feed the pigs to the kids that's so so
let's just see what the petition says
first before we go on in 2018 we should
be teaching children compassion towards
animals the school has made students and
parents uncomfortable by discriminating
against their beliefs by condemning
these pigs to death I think it should
have also mentioned and then feeding
them to the kids let's see what the the
school has responded with the school
said we respect the vegan philosophy but
priests in school is proud to serve the
whole community laughing here guys but
it's you know we want to educate our
students about where their food comes
from
and to do this in a sustainable way our
preferred outcome for this year's cohort
of pigs to enter the food chain as
planned for us then to sit down
and have a rational discussion about
whether or not we continues our pigs in
the future I mean okay so I'm by the way
I'm a very loud and vocal critic on the
left and how they try and witch-hunt
people out of positions are saying
things they feel that they disagree with
I agree with you on all of that I just
want to be careful in one aspect and
that's it works both ways there's a
sword that cuts both ways when L'Oreal
featured a hijab' in its advert and I
criticized it because I don't agree with
any job in principle but a lot on the
right way were offended and they
complained and they were outraged and
now the hijab' has been removed from the
L'Oreal campaign because she said some
statements against Israel yeah so the
outrage is happening on both sides of
the debate and I think everyone just
needs to calm down a bit really coming
back to that pic story this is a this
was pigs learned from the farm yeah the
pigs were always gonna be in the food is
a rural community we're very likely
their granddad's or their dads are
possibly farmers they raised the
chickens they take the eggs and then the
the chickens it is it is in the
entireties the circle of life and don't
worry worst artsy and it is utterly
absurd and coming back to michelle
central point just this week this week
last we were only part of this week the
week started with the churchill cafe or
churchill a picture church we learned we
learned being adored with imperialistic
regress later this week the film zulu
they happened to write on dalla steel
tubes pointing out that on that day this
is what they were celebrating
defeats very very briefly and the London
Underground many places they put a
thought for the day effectively an
inspirational thought for those who
don't know what last week it was the
anniversary and we're seeing it now is
the anniversary of the Battle of Rorke's
drift which is immortalized in the film
with Sir Michael Caine Zulu title in
itself guess what its history a hundred
and fifty British troops held out
against four thousand Sooners this it
was an act of heroism not Cologne is
that that's what they're selling yes it
happened of course it happened but
that's not something we need to be
celebrating I'm not saying don't talk
about it I'm not saying and raise it
from history of course not but we also
have to be honest about our history
that's our story about eating meat yeah
so I had when I was a kid my dad we
assist my six rabbits and what you're
saying about rural fields so my dad's
like this right looking at these six
rabbits and one day we're at home and I
must have been about seven years old and
we're eating some form of meat and I
asked my mom this is delicious what is
it and my dad said it's the rabbits that
you know where is runks I was
traumatized and so I've got no I'm not
have survived I'm not even I'm not vegan
and I'm not even vegetarian and I've got
no problem with this school ruin pigs
and then sending off to the slaughter I
just think it's a bit nasty kids that
were stroking these peas I then asked
when they want to eat them I mean there
isn't there's scope for once I agree
yeah obviously crazy yeah yeah I changes
one of the changes of recent years is
that the vegan
if somebody says I'm a vegan I take the
invitation away it's so difficult to
feed but also I have no objection to
people saying on the vegan I just think
it's them trying to impose it on the
rest of it vegans aren't generally let's
not be irresponsible do they do that
angry I've had a debate about this
actually I'm not vegetarian let alone
vegan but I do think the direction of
travel is in a is in a kinder future for
meat and I think for example the future
will be things like a biologically grown
in the laboratory meat where you don't
snore triangle but that's how we're
gonna move away from it but it is it is
a very it's a very cool industry isn't
it what a meeting it's a very one full
industry industry if I make it about
this vegan guy listen I think yeah
describe it something listen if you
don't like that take your kids are
different school and a story movie kid
on and what I'm now the school might be
doing the same easier solution you don't
like it don't eat the pork back teeth
have been told what is acceptable and
what is not acceptable based on what
people think of that thing you are
telling this is what you are telling
this parables yeah but you don't know
you do know I'm telling the parent if
you want to be a vegan my friend be a
vegan
I respect your time the second you start
dictating what other people can do
because of your belief system I've got a
problem yes got a serious problem and
that's what I'm offended by I don't care
what people think you can have your
opinion it can be difference but I don't
care it is where people are ramming
their opinions into everyone's
people are tiptoeing around afraid of
your remark it's happening both on the
left and right you're saying it's only
the left it's not it's both
cravenly gave you 150 plates could hold
against 4,000 Zulus dalla steel tube
station couldn't even keep it up on the
bloody wall and I do actually agree with
your sentiment that he was he was a
being a bit aggressive or over in his
head campaigning but this is clarify
something technically a petition isn't
dictating to anyone it's a piece of
advice
technically it's a that's the meaning of
the work but surely if the petition is
aimed at some Devere job is to sit and
say is this reasonable is what there's
something about it now the school in
this case this under did I happen to
disagree with him yeah I don't I think
they should have said look we've done
this for many years this is explaining
to people what the food chain is and
because one or two parents don't like it
I was looking at the other day with Jame
and Correa and she came out with an
opinion on transgender people's it was
basically what Jemaine said is that if
someone's had a transition from a man to
a woman with gender reassignment
she didn't regard them as a woman now
that's her opinion and she's entitled to
that opinion in today's day and age you
seem not entitled to that opinion I get
tacked gematria here's one thing we know
for sure with Germaine Greer is she's
know a shrinking violet so she
definitely can stand up for herself and
she's kept to that opinion